there is hope for video game movies
after all folks there is finally Oh
because Warcraft is right around the
corner really hope that one's good
Ratchet and Clank so Ratchet and Clank
is a CGI animated movie based off of the
Ratchet and Clank video game for Sony
Playstation this one is directed by the
director of Dylan dog starring Brandon
Ralph Jayden is here that that's a real
thing long story short Ratchet isn't
nobody he has hopes he has dreams the
super baddie in the galaxy who
has his big device that blows up planet
so now ratchet has a step up and stop
super baddie only thing is we've
seen Star Wars and the force awakens so
the just doesn't impress me much
just both did it better it's all I'm
saying what happened with this movie
where did we go wrong how did we go
wrong how can you take a formula that's
just been laid out for you it's like
honest silver platter like here's the
Ratchet and Clank formula now just
translate it to film turns out the movie
feels like it's directed by the director
of Dillon dogs starring Brandon Ralph I
say the formula being laid out is a good
thing because alright here is a snap
here's a picture of medic and this is
metacritic now this isn't rotten tomatos
spot the Ratchet and Clank movie you
have one second to do it now gonna be
that hard you know why boom it's the
only red among all the green yeah red
that's bad Green good thing is this
movie's boring it's a snooze nothing was
interesting to me it's based off of a
video game video games are fun where's
the fun where's the excitement where's
the heroism but granted this movie did
have a couple of heroic parts I'll give
you that in the last act of the movie
finally started stepping it up to a
little too late at that point but it did
start the excitement doesn't start until
about halfway through this movie
excitement is a comparative term really
their action sequences that aren't that
exciting I thought ratchet was an
alright character it's a formula that's
been done and it was worked before so
why wouldn't it work now Ratchet and
Clank together that's a good Dillo on
paper and in all the games that came
before this movie this movie had
fanservice for the games for sure and I
like seeing all the easter-egg
fanservice e things but that's not what
makes a movie good that's just
fanservice does nothing for the
narrative of a movie this is what it
felt like to me alright you know when
your friend or brother I was a younger
brother this is an easy comparison for
me you know when someone ball hogs the
TV and just starts playing a game here
is forced to sit there and watch them
play a game
really you're not connected to the
experience because it's not your
experience it's their experience it
really felt a lot the same way I felt
like I was watching someone else play a
game and play a game that did they
weren't really playing that exciting
like the movie had a humor some of the
humor actually I chuckled in a couple of
parts most of the humor just fell flat I
was like this is clearly made for
three-year-olds and I know that's gonna
come out in the comments section well
this movie was made for kids or oldest
movie was made for the fans I've seen
those arguments come out a lot lately I
see it like this you can take anything
that sucks and say well it was made for
X and somehow that's a justification but
doesn't make it a good justification
Batman and Robin was made for fans of
shitty dialogue and crappy looking
Batmobile Fifty Shades of Grey wasn't
made for you Jeremy it was made for fans
of the book right well yeah I can't
disprove that I can't discredit that
because it is more or less true doesn't
make it a good movie guys empowering
right through this in the end I like the
characters of Ratchet and Clank enough
it's almost like you can see them and be
like oh they would be great in a video
game oh wait but really none of the
other characters had any synergy they
didn't mesh well the plot was boring a
villain forget it I just I don't care
about the villain or villains in this
movie nothing flow just felt like a
really boring video game version of the
really good videogames Ratchet and Clank
that we all know I'll say it's not the
worst thing I've seen but I will still
say I'm not going to remember Ratchet
and Clank and T - one day ya already
forgot the guns were cool though guns
were really cool in this movie they're
more fun to use in the game because
that's what they're from so just play
the game that's my point
alright guys so Ratchet and Clank have
you seen it what did you think about it
or if you refused to do that because you
want to hold Ratchet and Clank of still
being the games that you know and love
what's your favorite Ratchet and Clank
game whatever it is whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more